it's been a major question throughout
the Trump campaign and administration
and that question is how easily
influenced is Donald Trump right how
easily is he convinced about of whatever
and often we've kind of joked about it
but it's a serious thing it seems like
Trump will totally flip his point of
view on an issue sort of like if someone
tells him five minutes before he's
interviewed about something he'll just
go with what someone told him five
minutes ago right farm up prices but a
pharmaceutical drug prices is a good
example the entire campaign Trump talked
about lowering drug prices by
negotiating with big pharma blah blah
blah he gets elected he meets with big
pharma executives and lobbyists he comes
out of that meeting he's all of a sudden
no longer interested in negotiating with
drug companies like he had been saying
for months and months during the
campaign lots of these examples former
chief propagandist that's what I call
him I think his official role was chief
adviser chief strategist strategist to
trump yeah a Steve Bannon former chief
propagandist of the White House Steve
Bannon who's back running a Breitbart
now has admitted that yet Trump can be
convinced to do stuff stuff that's not
actually in his best interest Monday
night Bannon was interviewed by Fox
News's Sean Hannity and he said when it
comes to supporting Luthor strange in
the Alabama Republican primary which I
just told you did not go strange his way
and thus did not go Trump's way Bannon
said yeah
Trump was sort of convinced into
supporting Luthor strange and let's
listen to it and pay attention to the
language that Bannon uses here this is
not about debating the issues they try
to destroy Donald Trump the same the
same gang that's going after Roy Moore
is the same gang that went after Donald
Trump and I sakata tell you I think it's
some time later after tomorrow a real
you know review has to be done of how
President Trump got the wrong
information and came down on the wrong
side of the football here because I
agree with you I love mo Brooks and I
was really shocked to see mobile works
not getting to the second round okay so
what's Bannon saying let's put it up on
the screen because I want to point to
some specific words here and we can sort
of think about what they mean how
President Trump got the
information and came down on the wrong
side of the football here this is the
President of the United States he is the
person who has access to all the
information if he wants it if Trump is
getting what Bannon calls the wrong
information it's because he's either
being deliberately manipulated
strategically manipulated or he's just
ignorant which is also not a great case
to be making about the President of the
United States so the core of this
argument is if Steve Bannon is saying
well Trump was given particular
information to get him to support Luthor
strange despite the fact that he should
have supposed supported someone else
that means Trump is capable of being
duped or tricked merely by fine-tuning
the information that someone presents to
him if it's possible to get Trump to
support the wrong guy this easily just
by saying hey let's give Trump this
information and then he'll support the
person we want him to support instead of
who he should be supporting according to
Steve Bannon that means that Trump lacks
the cognitive ability to really figure
it out for himself it's interesting to
see Steve Bannon still being deferential
or at least respectful to President
Trump yeah because maybe he wants to
keep his doors open keep his options
open and not either guy who'd give him
the right information at some point
right parts been running a lot of
negative headlines but I think he still
wants access oh I think he definitely
does and he claimed in that first
interview he did after leaving the White
House that he is still going to be
fighting for whatever he identifies the
Trump agenda or something like that so
yes Steve Bannon might have his own
reasons for using the words he used
which we have to read between the lines
on instead of just saying you put
someone in the room with Trump and they
can convince them of anything because
that's not gonna really play that well
not surprising right the only surprising
surprising thing to me is that Steve
Bannon is even willing to admit it in
this way Trump is duped constantly right
Trump is duped all the time Trump's
voters were duped by Trump they were
promised everything from pick your list
right I mean tax cuts for the rich to a
repeal of Obamacare with a replacement
that's going to be beautiful to a wall
that Mexico would pay for to
renegotiated trade deals that would be
great for everybody
none of it's happening and I don't
that any of it is close to happening
today Trump is giving a speech about the
tax plan we don't know if there will be
like a specific timeline outline there
this is the era of the doop and -
candidate like supporter like candidate
right
Trump easily duped and also the duper of
his own supporters I just wonder if
because Trump has such a diverse cabinet
you know you have military generals you
have establishment folks in there and
then you have the outsiders and if
whenever he makes a decision he's going
to let some of these people down so the
people who get let down turn around and
say well we got duped on this one I mean
there's just so many different people he
has to appeal to yeah I mean I guess the
one wing is the insiders that are
increasingly out like who's left for
insiders Jeff Sessions is still there
Reince is out and and Spicer's le is he
I guess it's kind of all military yeah
but the military wing not necessarily
the Republican insider wing so yeah I
think that's a factor that when you have
such a haphazard lack of actual a deep
political philosophy
why wouldn't Trump just go with what the
last person told him that sounds good
after all he doesn't really have
opinions about a lot of these things
anyway he never has discuss this with us
on our reddit discussion forum david
pakman.com slash re d di t we'll take a
break the first part of my interview
with Elizabeth Kolbert coming up next
stay tuned for that gonna be fantastic
today's program is made possible in part
by Blue Sky binary forex trading major
major space millions of traders trading
Forex around the world 80% of them lose
money you need to understand basic
proper money management rules you need
to understand how to avoid getting
emotional in your trading you need to
have the appropriate base of knowledge
for forex trading and blue sky binaries
education course provides exactly that
blue sky binary is a leading financial
education and tech company they focus on
FX and they've got senior traders with
real trading experience offering a
structured and self-paced course and
that includes video on-demand it
includes online tests one-to-one
education sessions access to their
community of traders to exchange
knowledge and experience and my viewers
and
listeners can register right now at blue
sky binary.com slash david to get a one
week free trial which includes not only
access to their platform and training
materials but also a session with a
senior trader to get you up to speed on
the basics of forex trading continue as
long as you want for $99.99 a month
after that stop cancel resume as you
wish
you can get the one week free trial at
blue sky binary.com slash David